WOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
Welcome everyone to another Reddit video! Last week, I titled the video pure coincidence:
"Thanks i hate it". It was a bunch of wethe-
It doesn't matter. What's important is as it turns out there is already a reddit called Thanks I Hate It
So now we can go through things that we can go afterwards say "Thanks. I hate it" Let's just jump into it. Thanks, I hate it.
Cookies with Vick's. It's an elite combo. Wait, what is that? I don't understand.
Thanks I hate this meme I don't get it. What is it? What vapor rub?
*reads title*
laugh.mp3
Hate the look of a helmet but still want to be safe for a limited time
You can have your whole head printed call now. Thanks
Who wouldn't want to have that that's amazing, that's great. Thanks. I love it. That's awesome
I've been telling my white friend. He looks like Woody from Toy Story. He sends me this picture randomly Thanks
I hate woody now Jesus Christ, excuse me, this offensive not all when people look like woody. Okay. Thanks. I hate Balu
Why would you do that
Cool. Thanks. I get it Mary. It's not Thanks. It's thanks
I hate Donald Duck don't get in Mickey. I'm naked what difference does it make you never wear pants, right? I
Never thought about that. Of course Thanks. It's not rewarding at all. I thought it would be funny
I'm just annoyed if you're a junior your mom has probably moaned your name Jerome
Well, thank God
That's the worst thing I've ever heard Thanks, I hate Will Smith as Jeannie. Well, yes
Thanks, the genie is ruined I hate everything about this
especially the hands a fun April Fool's Day surprise
Replace the cream in Oreo cookie with yourself to give your friend a fun-filled cream surprise
That they will struggle to forget until the day they die. April Fool's. I am the cream
The hands why would you draw hands like that? What would you do? I would you to their Thanks. I hate Oreos now. Yeah
Thanks. I hate laughing now. I don't like anything anymore. I think we should just go through everything in life
Just ruin everything and then you can never be disappointed anymore. It actually makes a lot of sense Thanks. I hate the Loch Ness monster
How did I like it now? I don't know. It's
It makes sense because he's tap dancing. And that's what everyone does in Scotland right? Thanks. I hate mermaids now
Oh god. Don't ruin. Mermaids. Please. Do not ruin mermaids for me. Do you sleep No, let me sleep now
Do you know that mermaids in cartoon uses starfish as a bra?
Starfish has their mouth in the center of their underside
mermaids only use starfish to get their nipples
I love it. Don't tell me Ariel has the starfish. Don't tell me o star Arielle
Thanks, I hate Thomas the chain Oh God not Thomas the child don't ruin Thomas the child
But the scariest thing I've ever seen in my life what in the world
What were they thinking when they did Thomas the Tank Engine? I don't
Understand why on God's earth. Would you put a face on a train like that?
I don't understand and I will never understand Thomas the Tank Engine needs to die
I don't ever want to see it. Again. It's already ruined trained for me. Thanks. I hate trains now. Thanks. I hate it
Stop sending me this
Thanks, because I already don't mind. Okay, I don't care
Thanks, I hate popsicles now now y'all ride popsicles what have they done Edward sticking Bella's
menstrual cup in the freezer
Yummy popsicles. Thanks. My first attempt. I'm creepypasta beginning here go on me
Carpeted kitchen does that exist? I'm not here in UK. They want to put carpets everywhere. I don't know
Why can we put a carpet day? That's great, but can we put a coffee?
They that's what they say. That's literally all British conversations here. Thanks. I hate horses. Yes, of course. Hey
It looks like the top of the Tank Engine SWAT why of course I draw horses all the time
I know what it look like. They have the nose on the side and the big giant eyes the deadpan expression
Of course. Oh thanks. I hate it. This is not the right one
You know that mean that really old mean I'll just have to do this
I just have to do this and you will understand and if you don't understand then trust me, it's better for everyone
What is this depravity each morning? I put one uncooked ravioli in a thermos
I pour hot water over it steeping it like tea and then I drink it all day at work
I work at the White House and at the end of the day as I take the last sip of the tea the soft
Ravioli slides into my mouth and I eat it now on God's earth. Would you do that?
I think the fact that someone gets pleasure out of it is what makes it so much more sickening. Why would you do that?
Thanks, I hate people now that's one creepy pasta just the fact that he works at the White House makes it worse Thanks
I hate gummy bear waffles
That looks delicious
Thanks, I hate BuzzFeed I've always hated thirsty, but let's see what they say
It's finally time. We talked about the hot dad from inside out
What is wrong with you? Who has these thoughts?
I'm pretty sure there are better examples of why you can hate BuzzFeed but fine fine. Thanks. I hate BuzzFeed. Thanks. I hate it. Oh
my god
Somebody thinks I wish I haven't seen already. Why do I have to add more things to the list?
I didn't want to know this what am I even supposed to do with this information?
You might think this is insignificant but know this change is my whole world view this changes my whole approach to life
It's and why I live it
hell
Why would you
Feel sick, I just feel awful
Why am I doing this? Thanks. I hate easy cups now. It's peanut butter
Haven't you all realize that the master bowl is just a poke ball with Wario's dong stretched over
We must continue we must fight on once we're through with this
We will be immortal we can do this. I hate chicken. I'm not watching that I'm not
Thanks, I hate this
My friend's cat why am I laughing my friend cat eye surgery now he has no pants. This is like Donald Duck, isn't it?
Oh poor cat. He said me there is that kept pretty sexy says shamed awesome. Am I right?
Brofist if you agree, oh wait, we haven't hit 100 million. Thanks. I hate sneakers
Just imagine how far we'll be in 20 years behold - nickel
In the codsworth am I watching are they fusing music? Oh god, no
Why did someone make this stop
I don't see Thomas the Tank Engine refuses. I hate this video
Okay
Oh my god, that's the worst. Oh my god
Hahaha stop thinking. Okay. I don't need you
Hit don't rule your own cars Marie not cars. My favorite is a franchise
Cars, do we seriously a really good bill? I can't watch it anymore
You've been sick
disgusting
Despicable person I'm done. I'm absolutely done tuber simulator
It's now so relevant that it's got a brand new minigame
cranium drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine like game and you say there's more of
Course, there is new knowledge perks new quests and new pics links and legs guys
lake